l'association des victimes du cs de la
rue pailleron à paris donnait une
conférence de presse cet après midi son
porte parole a été formel nous refusons
d'avocats la fatalité at il dit il y à
de nombreuses fautes à différents
niveaux
les parents des victimes du crs
s'étaient réunis ce matin à l'occasion
de la conférence de presse que leurs
représentants ont tenu chez l'un d'entre
eux il s'agissait pour les porte parole
de l'association des parents des
victimes de faire part de leurs propres
conclusions
à la suite de l'analyse du rapport d'
enquête alors la première chose que nous
voudrions dire ce que nous refusons
absolument que l'on invoque la fatalité
certains commentaires certaines
indications du rapport administratif
le routard de la leyre tu le fait que
les enfants ne connaissaient pas les
lieux l'extinction de l'électricité
semble être autant d'arguments qui
plaiderait en la faveur d'une certaine
fatalité leur faisons absolument une
refusant absolument cette direction
le lisons qu'il ya des faux et que par
conséquent il ya des responsabilités
parmi les fautes sur lesquels vous avez
insisté par ce bilan ce matin
eh bien nous avons repris nous avons
commenté le rapport administratif qui
fait apparaître trois fautes importantes
qui sont d'une part la présence de
certains matériaux en particulier du
polystyrène expansé qui sont le fait que
les recoupements obligatoire tous les 25
mètres n'ont pas été respectées et que
l'autre par certains éléments de
structure était pas protégés contre le
feu à l'aide de revêtement d'amiante
pour madame simoni le fait de
reconnaître certaines erreurs n'explique
pas que l'éducation nationale ait pu
choisir un tel système de construction
au delà du drame de la rue edouard
pailleron il s'agit maintenant de savoir
comment à l'avenir
on évitera de telles catastrophes je
pense qu'il ya une chose très importante
a à dire ce qu'il y a énormément au
moins une cinquantaine de bâtiments du
même type dans lesquels dont les enfants
fréquentent quotidiennement et dans la
mesure où ce système n'est pas un défaut
d'un cas particulier mais du système
lui-même il est essentiel d'en démontrer
la faille et je crois que c'est le
devoir de nous parents et aussi
l'éducation nationale contrôler les
plans au niveau des plans reprendre tout
le dossier de façon à ce que s'il y
avait une faille énorme qu'ils soient
pas c'est qu'elle soit vraiment
contrôler sérieusement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]